this is Sal again I'm here at Stanford
Medical School with dr. Abraham Verghese
and what we're going to talk about we're
going to talk about the ritual of the
physical exam the bedside exam the
physical exam the Richer why do you call
it a ritual that's interesting that you
you call it a ritual yeah I think the
the lesson I've learned from hanging
around with my hands apology colleagues
here at Stanford is that rituals are all
about transformation a ritual signals
the crossing of a threshold hmm you know
we baptize to signal the crossing of a
threshold we marry to signal our
departure from a life of solitude
loneliness and misery to one of eternal
bliss yes
so our lives are full of you shouldn't
be laughing some no this is it resonates
so strongly with it so crossing a
threshold is why we have a ritual and I
would say that the act of one individual
coming to another and telling them
things they wouldn't tell their rabbi or
their preacher yeah and then incredibly
disrobing and allowing touch yeah I
would say that that's signals a ritual
of incredible importance yeah and the
fact that we in the postmodern sort of
medical world have stopped seeing it
that way yeah and just see the sort of
yes another data gathering tool may work
for us but I don't think it works for
the patient and I think that a major
disconnect between us and our patients
is our failure to see what they see
which is a profound ritual and which
they're highly invested and when we then
come and just stick our stethoscope on
top of them yeah shirt or don't examine
them thoroughly we are sort of short
changing ourselves of an important
ritual yeah I now feel short-changed
yeah that's like but I'd love to enlist
for you if I may those aspects of what
make this a ritual yeah so if you if you
look at it first of all there's always a
specialized space you don't examine a
patient out in the corridor as always
yeah special rule a ceremonial room if
you will
yeah mysterious looking objects on the
walls yeah a very specialized bed that
you sit on so that's another those are
all signals that this is a ritual then
when they when the physician walks
the physician often is wearing the
ceremonial garb which happens to be a
white coat fascinating yeah no this is
this is interesting just from an
anthropological point of view I never
you know you just yeah the physicians
are wearing ceremonial garb and the
patient is also instructed to disrobe
and you know gets a patient gown so yes
both participants clearly have it which
seems specially designed to put patients
in a position of weakness I know it is
we should be rethinking because I think
there's a major yeah and then the
physician then begins a systematic exam
which at some level is mysterious to the
patient it's not always clear to the
patient why the physician is thumping on
their chest or why the physician is
saying take a deep breath right cross
your arms or stand on tiptoe or take
your hand and touch your nose rapid you
know so there's there mysterious and
ritualistic aspects to it and very often
the physician is using terms that are
somewhat Latinate right and arcane and
utterly mysterious to the patient such
as fremitus and percussion and what is
fremitus me from addis means el you ask
the patient is a ninety nine and you
listen you said put your hand on their
chest and you pick up the vibration and
if they have consolidation or collapse
the the fremitus is not what it should
be compared to the other side different
remedies so with the sound or the it's
more like a vibration or the vibration i
see sound being transmitted through and
being picked up by your hand interesting
interesting so and then we you know the
thing that's most interesting to me
about the ritual is that the person
coming in might be a policeman a teacher
you know an entrepreneur but in the
process of putting on that gown and
sitting on that ceremonial chair they
have sort of been stripped of all that
identity yeah and they are taking on the
identity of being the patient yeah but
conversely I think there's something
very important that happens which is
that just before this the patient has
been vocalizing all their symptoms and
their complaints and you know at that
point the physician could order ten
tests and you know go and look at the
images but there's something about
physician then laying hands on the
patient right that sort of gives weight
to what the patient just talked about
right you talk about your belly hurting
and then this individual carefully
examines your belly it's sort of right
it's it's sort of validating your soma
you're right your body is being
validated in this ritual right and then
you know when you finally have the tests
all sent off they become sort of what
follows intuitively on the ritual first
having it validated on your body yeah
one of the things that I I the Mon
sometimes is that at times the patient
in the bed I feel in hospitals around
America has almost become an icon for
the real patient who's in the computer
okay you know the entity in the kitchen
sorry interface with to get to that data
structure they come here that's
interesting I've going to term for that
entity in the computers the eye patient
yeah be here and the eye patient is
getting fabulous care the real patient I
think has a need to feel their
complaints validated to feel it
validated on their soma right and to
engage in a ritual for which there's a
transformation and you might well ask me
what is the transformation that takes
place in this ritual and I think the
transformation is the sense of the
patient has delivered the story here the
physician in the process of the ritual
has validated that they've heard the
story and try to locate it on the soma
and the transformation is really the
ceiling of the patient-physician
relationship Wow and so you know I think
what has happened Sal unfortunate is
that because we have so much technology
what become very sloppy and the way we
examine patients you know I think that
we could we should be a hundredfold
better at examining people given that we
have real-time feedback with
echocardiograms angiograms and all that
instead of which I think people have
never been less certain of their bedside
skills what about this phenomenon just
talking to physicians I know in my own
family that you know there's so much
time pressure that there's young have to
see so many patients one every 15
minutes and all of this and they wish
they could do this but they'll say that
you know I have so many other things to
worry about in the paperwork and all of
that I mean is it realistic to - I think
that's a very real
but I think if you can do this well and
our goal at Stanford is to teach our
students to do it very well you actually
save time right because if you do a
quick examine you find that they're
tender in certain spot you can or order
the test that sorts just that out rather
than which I think is much more common
which is I don't really know what's
going on I'll take off every box
maybe something will fall out of the sky
right so I think a directed exam not
only fulfills the ritual but if you're
any good at it it'll actually allows you
to ask better questions in the tests you
order yeah and minimize the patient's
exposure to radiation and you know I
think the trouble is we get all these
tests and we get back results we don't
know what to do with we stumble onto
what we call incidentalomas if you hear
that term incidental well I have heard
that VIPs often get worst medical care
because they do everything for the other
day and they wind up with finding things
they don't know what to do exactly these
two were over diagnosing things but to
come back to a ritual I think we at
Stanford are very proud to feel that as
much as we represent you know this great
bastion of Technology and advancement we
also celebrate the fundamental ritual
aspects of the patient-physician
relationship which is best symbolized in
the physical exam that I think this is
why a lot of physicians originally want
to enter the field it sometimes gets
lost but this is why they wanted to do
it and you're right I think they often
get disappointed when they learn to do
this and arrive on the wards and find
that no one's carrying a stethoscope and
no one's carrying right me they cameras
telescope I think it's like a meeting a
cymbal run no you got it you got to
carry one of those yeah but they don't
carry the nyhammer and they don't carry
all the other tools which I once visited
my wife of the doctor and I wore her
coat I felt very good yeah did you drape
your stethoscope on the neck too oh I
did yeah I look very authoritative
that's that's a great signal that's your
yeah so I think that we have so much to
learn from our anthropology colleagues
about the importance of ritual I think
sometimes we operate as though medicine
is all about reason but you know it's
really reason ritual emotion they all
tie in together this is the art and
science no this is fascinating I'm gonna
reflect on some of the rituals I do now
to see if they are anyway very cool well
thank you for this thank you so much